I've been in the business long enough to
know I just want none of it anymore to
be a part of like the headline and it's
like something that you know as a grown
woman you can have more control over I
don't like getting poked under the table
because then the Class come out
Christina Aguilera seemingly claps back
at pink and their decades-long public
view as her and I have had history and
it had it hasn't always been wonderful
just you know don't poke the bear
anymore the singer opens up about the
drama on call her daddy without naming
names I don't need to be talking about
things that happened you know decades
ago like let's grow up let's Embrace
like now more than ever is the time for
that the most recent headline pink
Throwing Shade at Christina while
ranking her most iconic music videos
there's Lady Marmalade
I'm gonna put that down here at 12. how
come it wasn't very fun to make
[Music]
I'm all about fun and it was like a lot
of fuss and
there were some personalities
um Kim and Maya were nice I like to be
really really honest now pink quickly
shut down the idea it was a dig at
extina on Twitter
[Music]
but those words did seem to get under
Christina's skin don't pump me under the
table because I'm still not gonna be you
know I'm still not gonna be I'm not
gonna be baited anymore you know like a
long time you know it happened for a
long time too this happened even you
know after I had my babies a lot of
people because they're you know they
need some attention too they'll poke
into the table when no one's looking
then be like oh I I don't know why she's
so UPS I I don't know I just don't have
time for the petty boy or you know just
you know sometimes you know the
Celebrity Status stuff I think it just
took us 15 years and I feel like there
was true love and it felt really good
yeah we thought this was all in the past
we made up on The Voice just give me a
pizza just a little extra
they teamed up on the singing
competition in 2016. pink serving as a
mentor for Christina's team I haven't
seen her in years and years and years
and we we became moms we grew up and
we hugged it out it's that simple it
thinks phenomenal I love when you're
around long enough to have a full circle
moment and that was a full circle moment
for me because in all honesty I'm a fan
of hers and and
it was just a really refreshing nice
visit and we're guessing Christina's
visit to call her daddy is the last time
she'll be talking about the drama I want
to live a real life and a loving life
you know right just I want good things
around my energy space is so important
to preserve that and and for my children
foreign